hello everybody I'm Jesse Watters along
with Dan Donna Dana and Greg it's five
o'clock in New York City and this is the
five
[Music]
the battle over what the president is
now calling the crazy mullah report is
far from over
Trump ripping negative claims in it as
quote fabricated and totally untrue
he's also tweeting that because he never
agreed to testify it was not necessary
for me to respond to statements made in
the report about me some of which are
total BS and only given to make the
other person look good or me to look bad
this was an illegally started hoax that
never should have happened
and on the other side Democrats are in
total denial House Judiciary Chairman
Jerry Nadler has subpoenaed the
unredacted Mullah report and he and
other left-wing Democrats are also
refusing to accept reality if the
special counsel as he made clear had
found evidence exonerating the president
he would have said so he did not he left
that issue to the Congress of the United
States the malla report outlines
disturbing evidence the president Trump
engaged in obstruction of justice and
other misconduct the truth of the matter
is he probably should not be the
president of United States but for the
Russian intervention because Attorney
General Barr wants to represent Donald
Trump I think he should resign then
there's the liberal media melting down
they're still trying to complete a claim
collusion exists they wanted to conspire
they just never found the right
opportunity to do so I look at this
evidence and it sure looks like
obstruction of justice to me if there
was an active collusion proved proven
then I think what we have here is a case
of passive collusion the chapter on
collusion shows significant contact
between people on the Trump campaign and
with the Russians I'm not going to let
people say that you know CNN or the
media or whatever have been creating a
false narrative now this report is
plenty of proof that the questions that
have been asked repeatedly we're legit
it is funny to hear the media Greg claim
that they're vindicated after the mole I
don't blame them I mean it is
embarrassing for them what they've been
through I don't they have to go out
there you know and and face the audience
that they lied to for so long every
person that used the word bombshell they
need
to have them go to a giant chalkboard
and write bombshell 10,000 times because
whenever we give here in bombshell
here's yeah exactly here's the summary
okay the first you know that this report
was about one question did Trump collude
with the Russians wasn't about meddling
cuz we already knew that was meddling it
was about collusion the answer is no so
then you have an investigation to answer
that question which was kind of ginned
up over anger over the lots of the
election there wasn't any evidence but
they decided to do it anyway and then
what the investigation did was create
what's called proof out of a series of
unconnected instances in events that
each by themselves means nothing so now
you have part two I know which part late
but let me finish so part two is nothing
but this collection of stuff you already
knew about Trump that he's mad that he
has meetings that he wants to fire
people that he wants to hire people
nothing that's against the law
that investigation creates the belief
that that somehow is illegal it's a
complete sham the first part answered
the question but they still had to do
the second part anyway makes no sense to
me well I read the I read a lot of the
summaries but I I'm taking this home to
Louisiana it's worth reading before we
start responding to or making spirits
allegations about what's in it it is
thorough it is it is deeply sourced and
what I like about the way that the
Special Counsel handle it is that he
addressed all of these important
pertinent questions about the Russian
interference and Medlin and while there
was no so-called collusion which no one
ever defined or literal collusion there
was a lot of penetration were you
reading the same report there was a lot
of Russian whoever that tried to make
contact with the Trump campaign and
guess what the Trump campaign one of the
information but there was no collusion
all right but it's worth to read because
if you want to protect our democracy if
the president wants to clear the air
then let Congress complete its job have
a little oversight it will not mess
baseball season I swear to me I might
put my only point is I agree read it the
media should not be trying to
criminalize casual behavior that's what
the part what they're doing with part
two it didn't seem like they were
thinking about protecting the democracy
I mean if you now know that the
President of the United States Democrats
president Republicans President wasn't a
traitor and wasn't an asset of Putin you
should be happy about that but instead
they're just cherry-picking it and said
all this was happening this was
happening so they haven't really grasped
that Dana it seems like everybody's just
kind of seeing it for what they saw it
before it was really a little bit just
as whenever members June 16 2015 when
President Trump came down the escalator
and now she's gonna run for president
the greatest story about him every new
cycle is about him and this ever since
this report came out it's still all
about him the main headlines to me we're
like Barry didn't I'm like the Russian
interference was deeper and broader than
we thought there was an ability for the
hackers from the GRU to be able to get
into a Florida vote computer that's what
he didn't change at the outcome but they
were able to do it and I wonder about
this in addition to the origins of the
investigation into the Trump campaign
why isn't anybody asking Obama Brennan
clapper like how could you let this get
this far why are you not you are
responsible for protecting the election
integrity of the United States and I
think that that might be a question of
this was a catastrophic failure aside
from the fact that you didn't want to
look like you were putting your thumb on
the scale for the campaign why did you
fail well I could tell you that a little
bit I know in terms of the DNC and we
were informed what was happening but it
was too late because the Russians had
already spent almost a year inside of
our systems and by the time we got to it
we were wiped out and a year before that
why what happened I wasn't chair so I
cannot speak to that also that you guys
never actually handed over the server
leaves I handed over a replica because
replica but yeah but it was sorry
replication
because we have to figure out we had to
figure and you see this another thing
this report goes into deep analysis of
what happened that they did get the
information they needed to establish
that it was the Russian that it was two
GRU and the replica was necessary had we
turned over our brains we would not have
any lates to stand the DNC was not in
charge of protecting Florida's election
system right that is not anything in
security what my question would be which
is asking the government for
accountability like what happened there
all right let's get down in here here's
my problem with this whole case right
this is as greg summed up this could
have been summarized on an index card
not a 400-page report there's no
collusion I'm sorry I wasted all of your
time Bob Muller that should have been
the entire Muller report instead we have
a 30 million dollar opinion piece
written which by the way lays out yes
that the Russians don't like us no
surprise they've never liked us but
leaves out conveniently the one
documented instance of known collusion
we have a foreign spy paid for on the
record by Hillary Clinton's team who
says he got information from Russians
how is that not in a report on Russia
inclusion this is not a ridiculous
question if you're a rational person
that's why the ball is in Congress Court
Congress has the ability question is the
report though there's a lot at the time
nobody believed it was the Russians
that's why more than 56 pages of the
first 100 and some of our pages is about
they establish it was the Russians
because remember people didn't believe
it at the time no III mean I think a lot
of people understood these are our foes
and they are always trying to mess with
us it's a mutually distort destruction
kind of Intel thing I don't think they
were targeting one specific party the
problem we had with it is yes if we're
interested in the Russians trying to
hurt our democracy why does the angle of
disinformation to the Hillary Clinton
campaign not interest any
entrepreneurial journalists out there
why is nobody looking at this by the way
the New York Times I think is finally
starting to come around to that story
that they may have been screwed over by
Russian disinformation the new your time
here and some rumors I saw a piece of
the daily call that even the time to
start
say hey maybe we like the Daily Caller
is now reporting on the New York Times I
love this right now a caller broke the
stuff on how it restored president Trump
then candidate Trump each and every day
say come on I want more WikiLeaks I want
more and because that's a lot more dirt
on it that's what Trump does when he
gets up I mean that's when I when I said
about that part too and the abstract we
know who doc this is we got a 30
million-dollar book report on Donald
Trump's behavior and but the thing is
what the media is going to do there's
gonna take absence of evidence and
they're gonna say that doesn't mean in a
sense it's gonna be he's guilty like
what's worse though think about it like
Hillary Clinton paid behind the scenes
to get negative information Trump in
front of the cameras like hey WikiLeaks
she got some stuff I mean really what's
worse I mean Hillary actually paid for
the information and got it I mean I
don't get the double stand I think she
should run again and they could settle
this debate yes